and i think the green party called us
called women like me non-trans women i
mean
[ __ ] off it's no
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you're bored with people arguing on
the internet over subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts
we ask the experts our guest this week
is a controversial women's right
campaigner
pozzi parker welcome to trigonometry ah
thank you very much i
added the word controversial to your
introduction i think it's merited i
think that's fair to say it
controversial yes to assert what i do
yeah yeah well uh
for anyone who doesn't know what you do
tell us a little bit about who you are
how are you where you are particularly
this chair right now what's been your
journey through life that's brought you
here
okay so about 2015 i when the tories
were elected i was a firm
labor member and had always voted labour
in my adult life
i'm jewish by the way and
um and the tories got elected and i
think most people are really shocked
after the coalition i think everybody
thought that
that good old jeremy was going to get
his chance thankfully he didn't
and uh and i joined this massive lefty
forum and it was called amazing lefty
women or awesome lefty women
and and i joined when i was about 500
members and it went up to a
20 000 membership and mainly women
very disorganized having no clue just
whining about what was going on
but then something interesting started
happening and that was
lots of men who identified as women
started joining and i
sort of i was a bit skirting around it
didn't couldn't really understand what
was happening there was lots of sort of
she
and oh my gosh you're so stunning and
brave those sort of lots of falling
and when you say lots of men how how
many are you were talking when you said
lots was it a few people
were about 20 sort of you know and and
they stuck out a mile
many of them looked um like truckers in
a dress
uh and this one man came in and he told
like a bernard manning type joke
and the essence of which i think the
punchline was
a feminist tied to my radiator in the
basement after a beating or something
some sort of male violence
type thing that generally women don't
tell jokes like that
are you sure you identify as a woman and
i could sort of hear this northern
sort of uh 1970s comic voice every time
we sort of read something that he said
it was
it was um it's really weird and he went
absolutely nuts at me
but that was bad but all the women
joined in
saying that i was hateful disgusting
transphobic
how could i question this man or woman
they would say
he knows better than i do how he
identifies and so then i was switched
on to actually if i'm not allowed to
talk about this and this is
obviously very serious and i need to
talk about it as much as i possibly can
fan like-minded people um had sort of
secret things online and then we just
noticed the language just disappearing
and then i was interviewed by the police
for making comments about mermaids
saying that i thought transitioning
children was abuse
and i talked about susie green taking
her son to thailand and having castrated
for his 16th birthday
do you thought it was an unusual gift
i'm sure my mom
decided
and so um and i just made these comments
and then i got
interviewed under caution by the police
and i think i was one of the first women
to be interviewed by the police for this
what was it specifically that you said
sorry
so there's a couple of there's a couple
of really sinister things about this
number one it was six tweets it was
things like transitioning children is
abuse
i think i'd um i'd so i'm banned from
twitter forever my
ip address is banned uh and i've said
they'd had um
i could get a russian made to sort you
out with any ideas i can't be bothered
teamed up with magnum ice creams and so
i sort of said it was a bit like
uh hey kids do you want us some sweeties
you know come
and it was a bit grooming and i'd made
comments about that
uh and i'd also said that she'd
castrated the
boy um and the police
approached twitter who released my
contact
information and this was at a time where
they couldn't get a jihadis address
but they got my my details released from
twitter which is why i think by the time
i was interviewed it was february and
i'd made the comments the september
before
so that was that was quite sinister i
thought and what was the police process
like was it just one interview was it a
series of interviews
there's one interview it was about an
hour and a half
um they text me right so
they um they text me and said oh we'd
like to get in touch with you and i just
ignored it because i
had no idea that the police texted
people
can we interview you and so i thought it
was like a prank and somebody managed to
get my number
um and they persisted and so i i phoned
him back and it was this cheap
cheeky chap from yorkshire who was uh
well you know we've all had
conversations about it around the dinner
table he was all lovely and friendly
and then i spoke to my sort of online
group
and they said you should get a solicitor
don't go to that interview
without someone so i got a solicitor who
is this six foot
four very posh older gentleman um
the sort of guy that was so posh he
could stop in the middle of a sentence
and people would just wait
until he continued you know that sort of
that gravitas
and he came along with me and i wrote a
pre-prepared a prepared statement
and just that was read out but she had
given the police
a five page um account
of my tweets and most of that was
her life story with her son and why he
transitioned
and that was read out in full in the
uh police interview and they've sort of
said things like
did you know that actually sex
reassignment surgery
doesn't include castration um
just mind-blowing like what what did
they think that
sex reassignment surgery actually was
did they honestly think that boy came
home
with his testicles intact you know it's
just it was insane and they
called me hateful for calling janet mock
a man
um and at the end of it they sort of
asked my solicitor what
what he thought they should do uh
because i
i hadn't spoken i just sort of had to
sit there defiantly and just say no
comment
and obviously i've watched a lot of
movies i thought i was quite good at no
comment
and they recommended it to the cps
they pushed it forward to try and get me
prosecuted for
malicious communications hate speech a
conspiracy
because other people had said similar
things to me so it was like there was a
conspiracy
against susie green not that she's a
public figure receiving
millions of public money or certainly
half a million of lottery funding
to go and spread her odious little
message to small children
and what was the result of that uh
prosecution
they didn't they didn't go forward with
it so the cps decided there wasn't
enough evidence
surprisingly yeah that was so shocked
okay and uh you're wearing a t-shirt
with the definition of
uh a woman uh and that is part of a
campaign that you
then organized yes so tell us about that
so in about july
of um there's been a couple of
controversies about me by that point by
women from my own side
um nasty defamatory horrible typical
leftist behavior
and so i was i was a little bit
controversial at that point within my
own movement and i wanted to do
something
that sort of what was the essence of
this what was really going on and what
it was is we couldn't talk about being
women anymore
so we couldn't use a word we couldn't
use female language
and people knew exactly what we meant
like women were beginning to
be told that we had to put cis in front
of our name or that trans women are
women
and so i wanted to get this word back
and i thought well
i think if we put something first i was
going to do a times advert but i didn't
have 40
grand um if we're gonna
push these people like what basically we
need to do is we need to
allow these trans activists to speak
because when they speak
everybody will hear just how insane
their demands
are and we knew that if we put something
really neutral
up on a billboard that said woman the
definition of woman that they would kick
off and they would have a real big
problem with that
and they did and the way i did it is i
raised money through selling t-shirts
and stickers and you say they've got
insane demands
what are their demands well they sort of
say trans rights
um and then you say well what what are
those rights
because as a man or a woman in this
country you're allowed to pretty much do
the same sort of things you know i'm
i have a little bit of right when it
comes to maternity because actually
growing a baby inside your body is
something i think deserves a little bit
of room uh
but generally speaking i don't know what
rights they don't have
except to invade women's spaces that
seems to be
the beginning and end of the demand is
the demand
so transgenderism is uh to
uh pretend to be the opposite sex or to
lie about your sex and
and transphobia is the refusal to
believe that lie
and you say invade women's spaces so
what do you mean by that is it changing
rooms is it
toilets is it it's every it's all of
them it's all of the things that we've
carved out of a society that we say
that's for one sex or that's a that's
for another so
anytime that a woman goes into a a
toilet you know it's it's a different
experience to a man
the majority of the time for start we
have more things to remove in order to
do it so we're much more vulnerable
because we're in a bigger state of
undress most of the time
and we also have other functions in a
toilet so
i don't want to share that with a man
and quite frankly men's toilets and
women's toilets
are very different spaces you are a lot
more dirty
generally as a as a group of people well
i think well
i'm triggered it's like an undeniable
reality
i've gone into both toilets just to make
sure sorry poisy it wasn't the safe
space when i was there but
and just like you no charges were
brought
not yet anyway um but posie you use
quite i i would say a lot of people
would say
some of the language that you've just
used and you're perfectly entitled in my
opinion to use it
but a lot of people would consider it
inflammatory so when you talk about
people pretending to be the other sex
about uh lying about those things uh you
know both francis and i we work with
trans people in comedy uh we've had a
trans guest on the show
i have i know personally people who are
trans right and
there is such a thing as gender
dysphoria right would you accept that
i think there is a i think very rare
cases that
there may be something that people label
gender dysphoria yes
and and the theory currently is
scientifically that something happens in
utero where
the the fetus is bombarded with certain
uh
is there is there i believe there is
peer-reviewed
quality no there isn't there isn't okay
well let's say there is the assertion
then yes that that is the case okay
uh so there are people and i know people
who who are like this who say look from
the age of three i've known i was the
opposite sex
that has never wavered i've been that
way and the earlier i transitioned the
better it would have been for me
i'm 50 years old now i am the opposite
sex to the sex with which i
i was born and i could not be happier
and my life is now
completely different i fully
transitioned chemically
and physically i've had the surgery i've
been reassigned
is that someone pretending to be the
opposite i mean they've gone to quite a
lot of trouble haven't they to
be a different it it's immaterial
whether or not that person is
absolutely right in their belief i don't
really know how we could explore
that to find out if they are right um
but it's immaterial to me
and this and women's spaces whether or
not that person
really believes it or just gets aroused
you know it doesn't it's that doesn't
matter to me still women's spaces and
they are not coming in
well no but my point is uh about the
language
to start with we'll get into the second
point but my point is about the language
someone who has gone through an
extensive
expensive painful difficult process
to completely alter their body and mind
as it turns out
that which home hormones do right
are they really pretending to be the
other sex are they lying about this
pretending
are they pretending to be the opposite
sex well they're not the opposite sex
so they can only be pretending because
they're not the thing
that they say they are um if you look at
somebody like juno roche who's written
about uh his experience transitioning
just the language that they use that
many of those people use and
india will be when he was on um
big brother he acted he acted
absolutely like a man he shouted in a
woman an 80 year old woman's face
i am a real woman and did this
and said you know let that penetrate
which i thought was a very interesting
term
uh for him to use but he he absolutely
acted like a man he he massaged his
uh naked uh brand new breasts
every night on the television his he has
a
he's a father to a child and a lot of
these men that transition late
it's just it's so absolutely destructive
to their families
um to their children i've spoken to
children that there's not a word for
children whose parents transition
but they go through a lot of grief and a
lot of gaslighting before
their parent transitions and then women
are called trans widows
and with these men and i would i don't
know enough about india to comment and
to group him in
uh this category but i've read so many
accounts
of autogynophiliac men who talk about
selfies who withdraw from their intimate
relationships
um who you know it's it's
it's too even if they go through the
full surgery
there is too much evidence that i've
read to suggest that the majority of
them
uh these days the ones that are vocal uh
are just it's just a fetish but it's
it's beyond
like most people's fetish where you take
it off again it's the it's embodying
uh a woman's body and falling in love
with yourself as a woman
we had india willoughby on the show and
this is another thing
you you you kept calling india he right
india said to us i'm a woman i'm
perfectly happy to call hershey
as a matter of politeness whatever i may
or may not think about it
right we had her on she talked about her
experience she's the example i was
talking about earlier where
it's someone i i think i remember asking
her
um if you could have transitioned at
five
would you and india said absolutely
right and throughout talking to her i
mean i think it's fair to say for both
of us that we were
persuaded by her experience that
this was a genuine case of someone with
gender dysphoria
so why why are you so militant
about calling india he about insisting
that this is a fetish
when i think if you listen to someone
like that and hear their story
you i mean i i genuinely can't
understand that somebody would go
through everything that she's been
through
just because it's you know it's a fetish
or a fad or whatever i
got a genuine sense this is a person
who'd been struggling a lot with their
identity
and came to a position with where
they're happy now with with who they are
right do you know what i'm saying i do
know what you're saying
so why call her he and insist on that
why is that so important puzzy
because when you're talking when when
you describe men you have to
you have to be able to use language it
makes sense that doesn't
uh cloud what's really going on so if i
if i decide that i'm going to go down
the road of of using
she then that's a thin end of the wedge
and the end of the wedge is that when we
talk about a man who's raped women
we call him she or then uh when there
was a
there was someone on a tube attacked in
a tube station
and it was by four women and it wasn't
by four women i think
i think there were four men uh but we we
then
can't talk about male violence because
we're talking about
she and woman so i just absolutely
categorically
refuse to do it for a start i don't see
india remotely
as a woman i when i look at india i see
a man when i engage with india which i
did on
this morning i definitely read him as a
man
that's and so you would and even if
you knew somebody personally and they
said to you i'd prefer to be
is as referred to as she you would still
insist as referring to them as he
probably wouldn't refer them to them as
anything yeah if i like the person and i
do have some friends who are
trans um most of them are very
uh they see themselves as men now
i think they've come through the other
side of it and and some of them question
what nurse they've done to themselves
so i i probably would avoid pronouns
altogether
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sort of sit
with somebody that i like or respect and
and try and upset them when i was on
this morning i think i
referred to india as they but uh i
certainly wouldn't say she
well i by the way i know we're pushing
back against some of the things you're
saying it's not because we're entirely
in disagreement with everything but that
point particularly strikes me as an area
where
we sometimes it's tempting to throw the
baby out with the bath water i think
politeness and you know
a certain amount of consideration for
people's experience is also important
i do think we overdo empathy in our
society absolutely and it's been
weaponized as a weapon against people
and there is a lot of evidence now a lot
of people are unhappy to have
transitioned
yeah that is absolutely the case so
we're fully on board with that
um so explain to me the safe spaces
thing because
trans people have always existed right
is that fair to say
yeah okay so where would those people
have peed before someone who dressed as
a woman had a male anatomy it hadn't
transitioned in any way
but dressed as a woman tried to look as
much as they could as a woman
would they not have been in women's
toilets this whole time well they may
have been
intimidating women in their own spaces
all this time yeah
why is it why is it and this is again
we're two men so we may not get this
we perfectly accept that which is why we
want to have you on the show
but why is it necessarily intimidating
if someone who
more or less looks female walks into a
female bathroom
uses the bathroom in a way that no other
woman can see them using right there's
no urinals in female toilets
walks out washes their hands doesn't say
anything to anyone
just like most 99 percent of people do
yeah why is that intimidating women
because a woman's space has a has a very
special
place and feel it's hard it's a safe
space and
it's such an awful phrase so terribly
badly used over the years
um but it literally is a safe space it's
where we go
that we can guarantee that we're away
from men and i don't say that as someone
who's like
you know i've never been a victim of
sexual assault i
um i've got very happy marriage i've got
three sons and a daughter
and when i think about men in women's
toilets
i think about my 13 year old daughter
and i think about my 13 year old self
and i think about women that have been
sexually assaulted and i think
who's more important to me and it's
never the man who needs to validate his
identity by going in a woman's space
it's always going to be the 13 year old
who would be terribly embarrassed and
feel nervous
you know if if you go for a bra fitting
in marks and spencer's
and it's your first bra fitting and you
don't want to be there anyway because
it's
highly embarrassing and it's awful and
it's you know
adolescence is our most um sensitive
time it's when we feel the most
embarrassment
if you're in that women's space and then
you hear a male voice
it's it's not nice and it's it's not
because you think they're going to
perv at you or they're going to attack
you or anything it just changes
the very feel of everything that's
happening in that place
that's why so those men that um
and frankly i don't know any i don't
i've never seen a trans woman that
passes which
could be sort of schroeder's cat as in
if i haven't seen them that means they
passed blair white for example would be
someone that
no he didn't used to though did he
before like hundreds of thousands of
dollars of surgery
but now you look at blair he also he
also
performs he performs bobbling womanhood
all the time
um i happen to like him but for me
i've seen him way before he looked
like he does right now but you know
there's plenty of women that look like
blair if you go to the same surgeon you
all look the same
i guess what i'm saying is if blair
white walks into a toilet where your 13
year old
daughter is why is that intimidating
well then you talk about passing which a
lot of trans people find really
offensive you're not allowed to talk
about that
it's called trigonometry for a reason um
then you're talking about passing and
then who gets to decide like we have
rules in society they're not so that
every second of every day we can make a
thousand decisions whether or not to
uphold the rule these are just the rules
these are the socially acceptable rules
that actually if you're a man and
if you're a man don't come in women's
spaces and toilets
and you talk about you know the thin end
of the wedge
what is your fear if we don't address
the trans issue head-on
and if you don't start protecting
women's spaces where do you think
it could end up in a few years that we
don't have any women's spaces
at all and then we don't have any
privacy and it's mass gaslighting
to sort of say to women that they
they're not allowed to feel
uncomfortable
they have to go override those feelings
already happening in schools
um and places with with girls where
so during adolescence you have the
embarrassment bit but you also have the
peer bit
so you want and i think it's an
evolutionary process of like pushing
away from your parents towards peers so
you don't procreate with your parents um
i'm very unscientific but
um so these girls
have this thing going on with them where
they have to fit in with their friends
they can't be transphobic and
unaccepting but at the same time
they're having to overcome their
feelings of absolute embarrassment which
is a kind of a global developmental
phenomenon it happens in all cultures so
it's not just over here
so that's that's one thing that we don't
have spaces um
but the the real harm is that children
are having their bodies
mutilated and altered in irreversible
ways
and that's happening more and more and
more and it's becoming almost
like people have forgotten their brains
that that people
think it's a great idea that parents get
complimented when
their kids go on puberty blockers
because they're so super brave
well i mean let's explore this a lot so
i'm a former teacher
and it wasn't really a thing when i was
teaching i only left the profession
last year right so tell us a little bit
about that what is actually happening in
schools now and particularly any
examples you can give
um well there's a whole bunch of weird
stuff happening with
sex and schools and what we think it's
right for adults to talk about with
children in a school setting
for example my 11 year old daughter had
a slide up when they talked about
hygiene
and one of the slides is you should wash
after sex
to a group of 11 11 year olds and when i
took that into school with the
with the uh the teacher police and
values do you have to do that
um
my sex life would be a little better now
well you are married mate
so um well also there's a transphobic
thing so
transphobic language um they also teach
trans
ideology as if as if that is
something that we all know when you say
trans ideology what is it that they're
teaching kids well that some people are
trans
and that it's possible to change sex so
they might sort of talk to kids
mermaids do this wonderful this is not
this is going to sound like i'm making
it up but it's not it's true it goes
into schools
and it's this long line of jelly baby
people
and you've got like a stixxing barbie
pink at one end and the other end you've
got brown gi joe and then the spectrum
of colors
kids have to pick where they are so if
you're a boy
and you kind of feel like you're over
here then maybe really you're a girl
and you're in the wrong body or maybe if
you like barbies
and trucks you might be non-binary um
you know and kids have to think about
that now as far as i'm concerned
kids should have to think about what
they're going to do at playtime
what they're going to learn what they're
going to eat for lunch
and what time school finishes so they
can go home and watch tv
you know that's that's a being that's a
beginning and end of what i think
children should be concerned with at
school
we have absolutely terrible rates of
maths and english sort of skill level
and so
i don't know if we've got time in the
curriculum to pump their
primary school heads full of this
absolute [ __ ]
is it not a really sexist way of looking
at uh gender or sex in this case because
you're basically saying that being a man
is about playing with trucks
when a lot of men don't necessarily like
playing with trucks i love trucks
right exactly and equally there are
women who don't like playing
with dolls and who who have a you know
there are many women who dress and
behave in ways that are very masculine
without
ceasing to be women so is one of the
reasons the feminist opposes
this idea that it essentially reinforces
gender stereotypes
about men and women absolutely well it's
it's all about the
the way that you behave becomes more
important than the body you're born in i
mean i sit here is
clearly very feminine um
maybe not in my mannerisms or in my
opinions
we don't see gender
[Music]
you're just like an orb to us but
um of course it's it's uh
regressive that we think that if
somebody puts enough makeup on and
a good enough wig or often very bad
um and clothes and fake breasts that
suddenly
they're more likely to cry at bambi you
know it's
it's and they're female it's ridiculous
and so you're talking about non-binary
um
i i i i'm going to admit this what is
non-binary i don't know what non-binary
is
ever so special it's basically everybody
because none of us fit into very male
very female do we
i mean my husband i definitely do
i'm russian we have only one gender in
russia
but it's it's absolutely nonsensical and
if you ask a number i think douglas
murray talked about this if you ask sam
smith what non-binary is he's like i
don't know i'm just finding out
well yeah makes it doesn't really exist
because it's just a made-up thing
you know i thought when i was a little
girl growing up i was really good at
maths
my favorite toy was a garage that my dad
brought us because we were so very poor
um and i like
all my friends were boys because i
really like playing star wars and
picking up um
crane flies in there and throwing them
at people you know that's how i spent my
my childhood so was i non-binary i mean
i had corduroy dungarees was i just
tasteless
um it's quite insane well you know this
uh thing about
children i think that is the crux of the
issue
because open-minded liberal people
if you want to be called she i'm not
that bothered honestly maybe i
there's things i don't understand enough
about it that but if someone wants to be
called chic
i'm perfectly happy to do it uh maybe if
i was a
someone with a beard in a dress i'd
struggle to do that and i might avoid it
but generally speaking
most people i think in the country
broadly speaking are going to be
like yeah whatever just you know don't
don't go too extremes
but when you get to the kids thing that
i think is where you start to lose
people and i i
i can give you an example from my my own
family i have three
younger sisters the middle one of which
told me last year that for a year my mom
reminded me of this
for a year she thought she was a boy
when she was eight years old
and she is now the most feminine
long-head
pretty loves pink glitter like in the
traditional stereotypical way
the most feminine woman you could meet
right now
if you'd said to my mommy when my sister
was a you need to take her give her
hormones
give her gender i think my mom would
have
more than words for you and i think that
is where a lot of this
issue really comes into into a lot of
conflict where you start to talk about
encouraging the transitioning of
children well in america you can have
your breath
sliced off at the age of 12. and you can
do it at 15 without your parents consent
in oregon right so and in one
hospital in marin county uh
of which of course there are thousands
of hospitals across america but in one
hospital alone they give
uh they do double mastectomies on young
teens uh four to six
a day and by young teens what a
particular age are we looking at
sort of 14 around that age but
isn't it also quite homophobic as well
because a lot of people
are questioning their gender isn't it a
lot of the times that they're
finding out their sexuality and
realizing they're attracted to the same
sex
well it's gay conversion therapy isn't
it you you get your
gender non-conforming lesbian and you
uh transition her into a straight
man but there's there's a big take-up
now of
just girls opting out of womanhood not
not all of them are lesbian
and they're just opting out of womanhood
because i wouldn't want to be a
teenage girl now in a porn sort of
adult society in which we live
where you've got trafficked 15 year olds
being found on pornhub
you know who incidentally pornhub are
the um
mind geek who they mind geek own pornhub
and they were going to be in charge of
protecting children from accessing porn
it's very strange that they haven't
managed to do it
who knew but but certainly with
effeminate boys
i think that is the main impetus for
people
you know you can you can erase the way
the gay with a bit of transition
and saying he was a girl all along and
transition rates
have started to rocket and also do rates
of children
seeing themselves as being a different
gender
but it i mean you can feed a society
as well i'm sure you both know you can
feed a society anything if you have the
right tools and the narrative
so we've got cbbc uh covered i am leo
which was a girl
uh transitioning she got a new passport
at 16 with the male
sex on it you know just think where's
where's
that that gonna go if loads of girls do
it and then say they travel to china or
russia
or anywhere and they say
we want to search you we think you've
got something on you and then they get
this
this 16 year old girl goes in a room
with a load of men because she's
male on her passport it's absolutely
bonkers
and once you socially transition these
children then they almost have no choice
into the the puberty blockers
because if you're getting this high
praise
as a parent and a child uh of
oh you're so great oh you're so brave or
you must love your
son's own daughter son so much in order
to do this
and the child's getting loads of praise
and all this focus and attention and
you're going to counseling
and you're tiptoeing around and the
child's managed to make mummy and daddy
call them by a different name and use a
different pronoun
and the school has to do it and you
become this king in your own life
why are you going to give that up and
when are you going to give it up
like when are you going to have the the
consciousness to be able to say
actually this isn't right i really don't
feel like a girl anymore
i think i'm a boy by that point you know
have you taken puberty blockers have you
totally
disrupted your body um you know it's
it's insane and doctors won't talk about
it like every place you go to
where you think well stop there they're
not going to go along with that that's
insane
the doctors are going wrong with it the
gps are too frightened to speak up
psychologists you know tavistock um and
portman which is the sort of gender
identity
specialists um and everywhere you go
the bbc uh feed it to kids there's a
story on
cbb's of this definite autogonophile
uh man who um transitioned
uh i can't remember what his name was oh
charlotte or something it was like my
dad charlotte it was a stunning and
brave family
and the dad who must have been
about 5 10 runs in the room like
giggling
and just and his kids and his wife are
sitting on the
sofa and he jumps on them like that
because obviously that's all
how all women behave in their in their
lives
and then we we had another one at a
local school
and he was the only person that walked
his daughter to school
30 she must have been 13 or 14 holding
hands
and i felt that was very much part of
his um
his whole uh need to be seen as a mother
so he'd missed out on those years when
he held his daughter's hand going to
school
so he made it and he'd pick her up at
lunchtime um i can't imagine how
distressing that was for her
but uh the children thing
i have no idea how anyone with good
conscience goes to work and
absolutely and contributes to this
idiocy
and wholesale abuse of children let me
try try again from maybe well it's going
to be the same angle pretty much but
there are people in this is my opinion
and you tell me where you're at on it
right
i suspect that there are people who who
do have gender dysphoria
right and they may be a percentage of
the total number of people who say that
they're trans right
and for those people they
might again my opinion reassignment
is helpful to them as an individual
right so isn't that really much more
about
kind of there's a group of people who
need that and then there's a lot of
people who may be
kind of being encouraged into that by a
society that's now obsessed with this
stuff
so isn't the challenge here is kind of
differentiated between the two
rather than taking what i would say is a
more extreme position which is these are
all
people pretending to be the other sex
what
look we have we have all types of
dysphoria we have people that don't feel
they should have two legs we have people
that think they should be blind
we have people that think that they're
fat when they're sort of five and a half
stone
we don't go along with those things and
say that it'd be good for you
to starve to death or it'd be good for
you to become a medical patient
uh or be blind um and i i would say
with uh gender dysphoria
it's kind of that's totally separate to
whether or not
you should be in women's spaces but
children a don't have the capacity to
understand
the ramifications of what their choices
are so
i think and i think our brain develops
to adulthood until we're sort of in our
mid-20s
so i think you should and then it's up
to you you know what if
if a man wants to have fake breasts and
invert his penis and cut his testicles
off and call himself sheila
it's not really any of my concern as
long as he doesn't infringe upon my
rights and my spaces
and my rights would be to go into a
female only space and there to only be
women in it
so it's not really any of my business it
doesn't affect me it doesn't
particularly offend me
as long as they know as long as i'm not
forced to go along with that belief
it doesn't really matter so and the
pretending
how are you ever going to know whether
somebody who is well versed
or somebody has a fetish or somebody is
is generally fighting every day to get
through it
i don't know if you'd genuinely know the
difference between those two people
or even if it matters it just it can't
be right that at 18
a girl in this country can go to a
private surgeon three months later have
a breast chopped off
and become a medical patient for the
rest of her life and take testosterone
which then causes vaginal atrophy which
is like the menopause and then they
often have
have to have hysterectomies in their
early 20s
which result in higher risk of
alzheimer's a higher risk of cancer
higher risk of
osteoporosis you know proper serious we
haven't even seen
what the the outcome of this will be for
loads of these people
but there are some people posey that i
know personally right
whose lives are horrible they don't
you wouldn't wish their lives on
anywhere being born in this way
and feeling like you're in the wrong
body
and you know we know that the suicide
rate is
crazy for people who are who've got this
and
uh you know they're all a lot of them
are depressed it's a very difficult
thing
to be dealing with surely for some of
them
who who have a genuine case of gender
dysphoria
they need all the help they can get
surely they do
and suicide rates don't change after
transition
yeah so that would suggest that actual
that these surgeries don't help
long-term therapy
would help really getting to the root of
what is it
about your body that you know being born
in the wrong body is such a
ridiculous concept because your what
your body is the thing that you're born
in
you know that is what makes you that is
you your body
uh they can't be separated well unless
their argument is
that you're you you have a male there is
a male brain and a female brain and
you know from scientists that we've
spoken to you know if you look at
someone's brain you can predict
with about 80 accuracy what what sex
they are just by looking at their brain
right yeah but that would be on size and
women have a slightly more grey matter
that's a
that's what pinker would argue sure so
so but my point is
there is such a thing as the male brain
broadly speaking
you're looking at me like you don't
agree but let me
lay this out and then you tell me what
you think there's such a thing as the
male brain such a thing as the female
brain
therefore theoretically based on that
it's possible for someone to be born in
a female body
with a male brain which tells them that
their body should be male
right no i think that's
a crazy idea where's the bit that's
female
how does that work that the brain is in
the wrong
like what you're talking physically
there's a physical aspect of a brain
that makes it female
well it's a brain that tells that person
that they are
male and they happen to have a female
body
but there'll be a brain that tells
people all sorts of things that aren't
true
it doesn't mean that that you would that
you would go along with it
and can someone really articulate that
they are definitely female if they don't
have a female body
like how would they know how would they
know what it feels like to be a female
if they're not one
i i suppose what they would say is that
that's it's just a feeling that they've
had and that they have always had
and this sense of discomfort of being of
wearing
being and identifying as a man
but then what but what is that like
identifying as a all these terms that
they're great but they don't mean
anything what does identifying as a man
mean does that mean that they look at
their penis and they think
that's definitely not mine yes yes so
that would be a body dysphoria that
would be an appendage dysphoria that
would be a penis dysphoria that wouldn't
necessarily
just because you reject a penis or think
that you should have a different body it
doesn't mean that your brain
is right or that there aren't other
psychological behavioral reasons
as to why that happens like
autogynophilia can happen
uh or any fetish rather can happen with
experiences
in very small children they sort of set
it i think um
grayson perry talks about it and he
reckons that this generation of children
are going to have fetishes about phones
because that's all their mothers do
is just look at mobile phones so those
things can embed in a person
more often with men and the whole
dysphoria thing
is is a misnomer anyway because where
are the heterosexual women coming out
as men in their 40s the mothers
who are coming out as men because
there's plenty of men that are coming
out apparently as women that have known
all their lives
uh and suddenly revised their entire
lives
to uh support that narrative but there
are no women doing it
and i'm that's that's the point
yeah no absolutely and because we don't
we talk a lot about male to female
transitions
but never so much the the debate is
never as contentious on the other side
why is that is it mainly to do with safe
spaces is it also to do with the sport
element as well where a lot of
female athletes in particular sharon
davis are getting incredibly angry
i can't blame them can you there's trans
men
so women that call themselves men they
are not going to threaten a man in a
boxing ring are they
they're not going to they're not going
to cause uh there's a
mixed martial arts fighter in america
colin fox
yeah i mean that's that's just it's
insane
we're totally with you on that one i
mean
people should trans women should not be
competing
in females yes i mean if
you if you don't think that you're a
[ __ ] idiot no offense to it [ __ ]
idiots that is a crazy idea
the idea that people should be
physically in combat
or even competing with with natural born
women
it's insane yeah would you explain why
it's insane
because i mean there are people out
there well look this is [ __ ] hard
mate
no well no men and women are different
men are bigger stronger faster they've
got bigger hearts bigger
they're more less likely to be injured i
mean these are basic biological facts
are they not
well yeah this is where the pronoun thin
end of the wedge thing comes in
okay so if we don't use female language
for men
we if we call trans women men and we
said
that man is going to win the cycling
race the women's cycling race everyone
would go no
but because that man is referred to as a
trans woman and then now
a woman in the press then people have to
have these conversations which are
ludicrous because if we just said
men and women he and she
there's there's none of this confusion
we're all very clear about what we're
talking about rachel rhys mckinnon
uh calls himself rachel mckinnon he's
he's a man
full stop you know when people go why
well the lungs the muscle fibers the
no because he's a man i did it's
we sort of get into these cul-de-sacs of
like you've used the instance and i
think india is the one that introduced
you to the um
the idea that that happens in neutral uh
this sort of mix-up
of uh whatever it is hormones or
hormone washes i think he said it was um
absolute nonsense but that's because we
are trying to explain
things that are so nonsensical and then
we're trying to put sort of intelligent
hats on
and explain why it's true why it's not
true it they're just men
that's it is there no compromise posey
is there no
middle ground where we can say okay fine
they're not women
let's say what they are is trans women
and we create a separate category
so that those people can get the comfort
that they need
they can have their own pronouns used
but for the purposes
of let's say sport and other fields
uh they're not treated exactly as women
in
in that sense but broadly speaking we
give them the comfort that they
they need to feel good about themselves
so in order to
compromise i will have to change my
language to something that i know isn't
true
but no i'm not saying you have to say
they're a woman i'm saying you have to
say they're trans women
for example it's a new category let's
say
no why i just don't i i think it's
it's really bloody offensive to think
that you can just
stick on some clothes and and demand
that i change the way i think because i
i don't think that
trans women is a nonsense term woman it
doesn't apply to those
but you don't think there's a difference
between me
and me having cut off my penis and
replaced her with an artificial vagina
and artificial breasts
is that not a different person and a
different type of person i think you're
probably a troubled human if you do that
but i don't think that makes you a
different category of human
no and what a lot of women uh in
in particular women that i know who are
very close to me
get incensed and enraged by the term cis
cis woman why is that so contentious
amongst women because it's women that
have to change all our bloody language
we're uterus havers i think in ireland
now you're pregnant people
i mean jesus christ it's i'm a woman
it that should be enough right but it's
not enough anymore because we have trans
women
and so now apparently we have to have a
prefix this is why
all the little tiny kind of placating
language right that all the things that
are supposed to be nice and polite and
kind
why they're so [ __ ] dangerous because
it means
trans women and i think the green party
called us non-tran
called women like me non-trans women i
mean [ __ ] off
it's no and i think what i hear a lot is
something francis and i have talked
about and he just brought up which is
women are angry about this [ __ ] yeah we
are yeah well i wouldn't use the word
andrew i use vitriolic
when sometimes you know you're having
you know the discussion
over dinner and you you know the trans
issue is raised and
as a man you sort of blindly stumble
obliviously into this
mind minefield and then you see women
who from every political viewpoint
come out and when they feel it's safe
they're not happy
no well it it's it's a proper um
i used to read the bunty as a little
girl little comic and it was called if
you can't beat them join them and i
really do feel that's what
this whole trans stuff is they've sort
of
it's they've come into the women's
movements and it's very interesting
because a lot of these men
uh so when the women's equality party
started like
like that there were trans women in it
right
and then they can't have a position that
tries to protect women's spaces
because there's already someone there
with a bleeding heart telling them how
hard it is for them
to pretend to be a woman all day long
now it's
it's i don't think men really get and i
can't blame you because you have another
experience and i don't know what it's
really like to be a man
it's brilliant it's [ __ ] great i'm
sorry
[Laughter]
as my as a great comedian friend of us
as a joey says better pay fewer feelings
but as soon as as soon as you hit
puberty as a girl
and you know this is global you become
the kind of public property
and i've been gulped at probably not so
much these days
but i've um you know 40 does that too
i'd call for you any day
but but as soon as as soon as you sort
of
hit a particular age you get male
attention
and i think that's why that's an
interesting thing when men
start dressing as women and they get
comments that they get
so hurt and injured and uh you know
rather a gas bile but we've had training
in this
as women from the very moment that we
have breasts basically that's what it
comes down to you know that's so much of
a
um that's how i think many that's why
men are more fooled
by men that dress as women because men
just see
makeup hair tits and that's a woman
whereas i think um i think most men
can't spot
a man dressed as a woman as much as a
woman let me ask you this because i
agree with a lot of what you're saying
not with everything but with a lot of
what you're saying and whenever i have
this conversation with people
i always have this thought in the back
of my mind which is
would we not have been having the same
conversation about gay people 30 years
ago
it's just in the head what they really
need is therapy are they just thinking
it
it's a it's a mental disorder or
whatever you didn't use those words but
you didn't and i'm not putting that in
your mouth but it's it's a
it's a it's some kind of thing in their
head and what we need to do is help them
to be normal it's a good argument and
it's like
that it's the one that the trans
activists use a lot
um and i think that the way we've dealt
with transactivism and transgenderism
generally is
a backlash to how terribly badly we
dealt with
homophobia and homosexuality um
but we didn't talk to children
about um being gay
before they kind of their sexuality
happened
and we didn't gay men never stood in a
room and said
you must call me straight and that's the
difference
uh the whole trans thing is demanding
something of other people that isn't
just uh
just to accept me it's it's making
demands
that goes beyond except me it's i demand
that you see me the way i see myself
um and gay rights never did that gay
rights was about i want to live my life
and i want to operate fully in society
without getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
me when i walk down the road
and loads of abuse and i think if trans
activism had done that
and said look you know it's we get
attacked
um we want the same rights as everybody
else which they already have
then i don't think we'd have this uh
the wall and the the interesting thing
is it's a lot of lesbians that are
speaking up against transgenderism
because they have absolutely their
community has been annihilated
not only are there very young lesbians
being transitioned
but also all lesbian spaces are occupied
by men
and so they don't really exist um and
it's a lot of liberal left-leaning
liberal women
that are going no we're not going to
have this you're not going to do this
you're not going to make women move over
for men
in our own space and you know i i think
there's a
chap on twitter that basically said do
people honestly think that all these
liberal live and let live people just
suddenly got up one day and was like
actually i'm going to be a raging bigot
i'm just going to pick
i'm going to pick one issue and i'm just
going to be an absolute [ __ ] about it
and i've totally switched and now i'm a
nazi no
and you talk about the thinner of the
wedge i mean a good example of what
you're talking about with the thick end
of the wedge is the case of karen white
in prison which is just
an awful case and just shows how in many
ways we've lost our mind
well in i think jeremy vine was on the
radio and he said something like
um karen white raped someone with her
penis
you know and that goes it is again this
is this pronoun thing and
and why doesn't if karen white if it's
sorry to interrupt
if you could just explain the case of
caroline to people who might not be at a
fa because we get a lot of
americans and viewers and all around the
world so karen white was a convicted
rapist that then got put in a women's
prison
and then surprisingly still had a penis
um
and surprisingly then went on to
sexually assault women
and he's not the only one and there are
they're over-represented in sexual
um offenders uh trans is so for a
percentage of the population
say it's like 0.1 in prison um they are
over-represented i think about 40
of prisoners who identify as trans are
sexual
uh offenders so that's when
and you know they could be twofold it
could be one that it's a um
a paraphilia which often you have more
than one so if you've got a fetish about
dressing as a woman you've also
got fetish maybe um pedophilia
or other sorts of sexual fetishes um
that's well documented by sheila
jeffries who's a radical feminist
um brilliant writer i haven't read
enough
um and then you have you also have the
case of
why wouldn't you say that you're a woman
if you're a sexual predator
and you go to prison why wouldn't you
say you're a woman
and the police in this country if you
rape someone and you get arrested and
you tell them you're a woman that gets
recorded as a
crime committed by a woman i read it in
the paper about that today there was a
case going on right now by the time this
this interview goes out it will be a few
weeks in the past you mentioned we've
got very little time so i'm going to ask
you one question and we'll do the last
question
okay you mentioned radical feminism and
this is i i know i feel like i've played
the bad cop throughout this interview
and this is another question
[Laughter]
i quite enjoy it actually uh but you've
been uh you've been great supporter
dealing with it
is that i mean i have to say as a man
who
has been repeatedly told that as a man
i'm not allowed to have certain opinions
that i don't know what i'm talking about
simply because i have a penis
i have a little bit of shading fraud
about this i really do because i look at
feminists being told to shut up
because they don't know what they're
talking about because they haven't had a
certain lived experience and i go
you guys [ __ ] created this yeah and
now it's being used against you
enjoy it am i right about that am i
wrong about that well there's loads of
mras that think the same issues
but no i'm not saying you're one but
there are there are
like the biggest the biggest sort of ha
ha ha this is what you deserve
you brought it on yourself i don't mean
it like that but no i know you don't
but it's it's he's on an all carnival
diet
jordan no no no no no no no i eat greens
as well then
i love peanuts i totally have sympathy
with that i absolutely do and sometimes
i listen i'm not a feminist anymore
because well why don't you believe in
women's equality posie
far too many [ __ ] women that's why um
in this movement it's uh it's
it's awful it's properly awful the the
the way women behave
in their own movement is shocking uh i
don't think men do it i don't know what
it is
i've thought about it often uh but i but
in my
life uh the people that have been the
most awful to me are women
uh and also i've i just i
sometimes hear identity politics i don't
like
lurking at the back of my head when i
read some of the stuff when people go
as a woman as a feminist as a mother and
i'm thinking well
that's all the stuff we're fighting
against so um
for me when i when i discovered that i
was on the wrong side of the left when
it came to this
i had like an awakening um and some
people may call that
a certain sort of pill i'm not gonna go
along with that
but i had a bit of an awakening when you
suddenly thought oh
okay so i've always thought that why do
i think that
let me explore why i think that why do
why do i have that point of view is
there any
truth to it have i really thought about
this or is it something i'm supposed to
believe
and the whole feminist thing um you know
all men are potential rapists and you're
like
and it's i sort of said to somebody what
what or um 90 of women have been a
victim of sex
sexual assault or all these ridiculous
sort of things and and there's a little
bit of me sometimes it thinks
well we have invited it we have sort of
you know we've
we've had this role of oh we're we're so
terribly oppressed and victim and victim
and victim and then these men want a
piece of it
and that would all be true if it weren't
for the fact
that it's men doing it so the invasion
of women's spaces
whilst we may have given language
perhaps it's
men that are doing it so
is it a woman's fault if a man then
tries to invade a woman's space
no it's not even if we provided the
language and and open the door
it's still not our fault if he chooses
to walk in
well if you've learned anything from
this episode it's that i'm a men's
rights activist
or is it otherwise known russian we've
uh we've run out of time so we've got
one more question for you and uh and the
last question
is always the same for all our guests
which is what is a one thing that we're
not talking about as a society
that we really should be talking about
it's a big one
it's pedophilia and the erosion of
safeguarding towards
children
[Music]
i think there is i think there is a
along with this trans wave and i'm not
going to conflate the two because
that's not remotely what i'm saying
however if i was a paedophile
and i was watching with glee at the
severance of
family control and autonomy like in
their schools in birmingham
and what our children primary
school-aged children are being taught
the fact that if you're a man you can go
away with the girl guides now and they
don't have to tell your parents the
parents of the children
and the sex sort of the way we talk
about sex in schools
and then pornography and the way that
that's easily accessible for
children and it all just it's really
uncomfortable i feel like i'm wearing
some sort of foil hat and should be on
the david ike show instead of this very
sensible and reasonable show
but it does feel that there's some
really uncomfortable things happening
with the erosion of boundaries
well there you go yeah uh ending on a
happy note as we usually do
no no that's great but this is why we
give our guests that opportunity to say
whatever it is that they think
if people want to follow you and what
you do do they go to the mumsnet
feminist forum
no i'm banned from that internet yeah
because i said that i wouldn't use the
pronoun they
right i'm banned forever from that you
can't find me on twitter because i'm
banned from
twitter so i'm the po i'm posey parker
on
uh facebook and i run a website called
standingforwomen.com
where you can buy t-shirts and the like
fantastic
uh do that and as always follow us at
trigger pod we will see you again in a
week's time with another great episode
take care see you next week guys thanks
for watching guys
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word
you